bonjour je vous présente je suis
monsieur Courdier gérant de d'entreprise
prprc j'ai une activité de placoplatre
faux plafond décoration intérieur
agencement
peinture et carolage je n'ai
effectivement de 5 personnes moi y
compris plus une secrétaire les types de
produits qu'on travaille avec on fait
des cloisons des murs en arrondi en
placoplatre des staffs comme ça en
décoration en milieu bon c'est du
plafond dessous des plafonds
sous plusieurs formes voilà des gens un
type de plafond qu'on fait il y a deux
types de plafonds plafond déco et
plafond en placoplate l'activité s'étend
dans toute l'île de la Réunion là ici si
on fait un contrôle d'aplomb pour voir
si la cloison elle est bien aplomb pour
demain matin si on a un meuble à mettre
tout ça comme ça il y a pas de problème
au niveau de la planété de la cloison
j'ai 25 ans d'expérience dans le
placoplatre et bon j'espère que ça va
continuer ça va pas s'arrêter
alors actuellement je suis à la
recherche des plaquistes des jeunes qui
connaît un peu le boulot surtout le
boulot de placoplatre c'est pas à la
portée de n'importe qui donc je cherche
déjà un qui ont déjà une expérience en
deux ans à 5 ans d'expérience qui
connaissent le placo on a des cloisons à
faire on a des plafonds des faux
plafonds déco à faire et d'agencement
rénovation ce que je recherche quelqu'un
qui est app qui a surtout qui a une
bonne performance dans dans ce rayon
dans ce métier surtout qu'on précise à
la Réunion qui il y a du plat quoi faire
mais bon je recherche quelqu'un je
recherche pas comme pas qu'une personne
mais plusieurs personnes ou un contrat
durée indéterminé mais d'abord on va
faire un essai pour voir ce que le gars
ce qu'il vaut
le plâtrier plaquiste doit
maîtriser les techniques d'isolation et
de cloisonnement avoir le sens de la
décoration et de l'embellissement
faire preuve de rapidité
être minutieux
être doté d'une bonne résistance
physique
un procès que je donne jeune s'il vient
de travailler avec moi c'est très simple
si il est curieux de savoir ce que ça
veut dire le placo au taux du placo il y
a d'autres produits mais qui concerne le
placo s'il veut avancer il veut aller
au-dessus de ça pourquoi pas